Thông tin cho Bộ Xây Dựng để làm mấy cái chuyển đổi
số ở Việt Nam thì nó có một cái mảng mà nó
liên quan đến cái hệ thống cơ sở dữ liệu và nó
sẽ đồng bộ các cái thông tin của thị trường tương tự
giống như kiểu bên Mỹ.
Đấy thì lúc mà viết luật thì cũng tham khảo thì tham
chiếu của Mỹ ở Trung Quốc đang muốn nhờ Thúy hôm nay
dành thời gian để cho mấy anh em có thể xem được
cái hệ thống MLS ở bên Mỹ nó đang vận hành như
thế nào.
Tức là trong này thì có anh Bảo là CTO và có
Bình là Dev Lead của công ty tớ thì mọi người trước
đây đều từng làm PropTech ở bên Mỹ rồi.
Nhưng mà giai đoạn trước ở giai đoạn này thì đâu đấy
nó cũng khác nhau. Đấy và đợt đấy thì mình cũng chỉ
là mình lại làm ở trên chỗ Boston.
Đấy thì cũng muốn là tham khảo nhiều hệ thống MLS ở
nhiều nơi xem là nó có những cái gì khác nhau không.
Và để mình có thể làm cái hệ thống của Việt Nam
ấy. Thì nếu mà Thúy tiện thì nhờ Thúy share screen.
Đấy để mọi người cùng tham khảo.
Ok ok
thì chào anh Bảo và chào Bình
thì mình là làm Realtor ở bên Mỹ
nhưng mà nói chung là Hiếu cũng reach out một thời gian
rồi
thì cảm ơn Hiếu đã rất là patient với mình
để mà thời gian hôm nay các thứ phù hợp được thì
cảm ơn cả nhà rất là nhiều
thì nói chung là cũng trong gia đình thôi
nên là mọi người có câu hỏi gì mà mình biết thì
mình sẽ trả lời
thì cơ thể bắt đầu ha
anh Bảo, Anh Bảo lead tiếp giúp em đấy nhé
Ok ok
Ok thì bây giờ em sẽ chia sẻ screen nha
thì mọi người muốn xem gì thì mọi người cứ bảo em
rồi cảm ơn
thì cái đầu tiên là bây giờ mọi người có thấy được
một cái trang ghi là
North Texas Real Estate Information Systems (NTREIS) không ạ
mình đã thấy được rồi
Ok ok
thì mình sẽ vào trang này ha
thì nói chung là hệ thống cũng khá là nhiều chức năng
với mình là Realtor thì mình cũng dùng một số chức năng
nhất định ý
và mọi người mà có một số câu hỏi gì nhất định
thì mọi người có thể chia sẻ
thì cái đầu tiên á ở trên trang này cái mình cảm
thấy nha
mình là người dùng mình cảm thấy khá là tiện
là có nhiều những cái app mà nó kết nối với nhau
ở đây
thì có một số app là mình hay dùng ở đây là
cái app Supra
với cả app ShowingTime
hai cái app này là dùng để mở cửa cho khách vào
nhà ấy
thì như kiểu là mỗi lần khi show nhà chẳng hạn thì
những cái app này là mình phải đặt lịch ở trên đó
là giúp mình đặt lịch với cả
lấy được thông tin của những người đã đến xem
thì cái này thường là thông tin này là thông tin cho
người bán nhà
là để biết được những ai đến nhà mình và Realtor nào
là người đã dẫn khách đến
có một cái app nữa
mà nó đang phasing out thì có thể là nó sẽ có
một cái app khác
nó sẽ lên
thì trước đây nó có một app nữa là nó cũng link
vào
theo kiểu là nếu đăng cho thuê nhà ở trên này
thì cái app đấy nó cũng sẽ giúp screen tenant
như kiểu nó mọi người submit application qua đấy
và nó có thể pull background check luôn
thì có một cái app nữa là nó cũng hay link đến
cái này
thì cái app đấy vừa phasing out ra xong thì có thể
sẽ có một app mới
ờm...
có một app nữa mình hay dùng ở trên này
gọi là cái CMA
cái này là hay dùng theo kiểu là để so sánh giá
nhà của mình ấy
tức là trong này có rất là nhiều cách để pull data
với cả analyze data luôn
nhưng mà một trong những cái tiện nhất hay dùng là ví
dụ như khách của mình đang xem một căn nhà
ờm...
thì mình sẽ xem được cái CMA này nó gọi là comparable
market analysis
là tí nữa mình cũng có thể ví dụ một cái đấy
nếu mà mình muốn xem
thì nói chung là nó cũng là một cách thông minh để
mà nó tự search sẵn là
là cái căn nào nó tương tự với căn của mình để
mình so sánh giá
ờm...
Thôi cho mình hỏi là cái này là hiện tại là một
không phải là MLS đúng không
mà cái này là một cái hệ thống app mà downstream lấy
data từ MLS về
và sẽ có nhiều cái đơn vị khác nhau làm những cái
app để mà phục vụ
cho Realtor đúng không ha
ờm... đúng rồi đúng rồi Matrix cái này là đúng là MLS
chỉ có Matrix này thôi
nhưng mà như của bây giờ nếu mà mỗi mỗi cần một
Realtor nào đó chẳng hạn
họ sẽ phải trả membership để mà họ có được access với
MLS
với cả họ có được login chẳng hạn
thì tất cả những cái app này là trong cùng một cái
login đấy luôn
họ được tất cả những cái app này
ờm... tức là cùng một cái login là họ sẽ thấy được
hết những cái app này
Tất cả những cái app này là các app downstream đúng không?
Tức là ví dụ như mình đang mường tượng.
Tức là theo cái kiến thức của mình về MLS.
MLS nó sẽ là một cái hệ thống giống như là centralized
ở từng bang một hoặc là ở từng cái khu vực một.
Thì là bên Realtor hay Realtor agent hay là các agency sẽ
đưa update những cái data về housing, về listing lên trên đó.
Rồi sau đó ở trên đó nó sẽ có một cái phần
là ok là tôi muốn các listing này nó sẽ được public
ra downstream để cho các app khác như là Zillow hay Realtor
hay những cái app mình đang thấy trong này.
Thì mà họ có thể là các vụ trên đó.
Thì là cho mình hỏi là cái phần này là nó chỉ
là exclusively là các app downstream thôi hay là nó là có
luôn cái MLS ở trên luôn luôn rồi ha?
Tức là cái này là nó kết nối với MLS.
Như bạn nói như anh nói đúng là cái này là kết
nối với MLS.
Nhưng nó hơi khác một chút.
Ví dụ như là Zillow chẳng hạn.
Em dạy ví dụ như thế này đi.
Ví dụ như là tất cả những cái app trong này nó
như kiểu kết nối giữa Microsoft Excel với cả Microsoft Word, Microsoft
PowerPoint.
Thì nó như kiểu là nó cùng một cái package nhưng mà
nó kết nối và nó là những cái khác nhau.
Còn ví dụ như MLS mà kết nối với Zillow chẳng hạn
thì hơi giống như kiểu là mình muốn kết nối PowerPoint với
cả Canva chẳng hạn.
Thì nó hơi khác nhau với cả nó là độc lập, nó
danh thu nó khác nhau ấy.
Đúng hơn là một là MLS.
Có thể nó là partial ownership hoặc là nó là những cổ
bản quyền để kết nối với nhau.
Ồ.
Đại loại là như vậy.
Đó.
Thì...
Có hai loại mà mình hay dùng nhiều nhất.
Mình sẽ dùng hai loại nhiều nhất.
Thì dụ như là Realtor của mình.
Thì...
Mình sẽ có thể đại diện người bán hoặc là đại diện
người mua.
Đúng không?
Đại diện người mua nhá.
Thì ví dụ như là đại diện người mua thẳng thị thương
ấy.
Là mình...
Ví dụ đây là mình sẽ lấy một cái...
Một cái note.
Ví dụ đi là...
Mình là người mua thì mình có hai loại.
Một là ví dụ như mình...
Represent người mua.
Thì người mua có thể...
Một là họ đã có một cái nhà nhất đấy.
Họ muốn xem rồi.
Hoặc là họ mới cho mình tiêu chuẩn thôi.
Và họ chưa tìm được nhà.
Ừ.
Thì cái đầu tiên á...
Là ví dụ họ đã có một cái nhà cụ thể chẳng
hạn.
Thì ví dụ mình vào đây...
Mình đánh cái số địa chỉ nhà ra.
Mình ấn vào.
Thì mình cũng sẽ tìm được luôn...
Đây là tất cả những cái listing liên quan đến cái nhà
đó.
Mà đã ở trên...
Trong...
Đã ở trên MLS.
Trong lịch sử luôn tất cả...
Thực trì database ở đây...
Nó cũng không có được lâu lắm đâu.
Nó cũng chỉ có tầm chục năm đổ lại thôi.
Nên là những cái căn nhà...
Mà có thể...
Bán năm chín mấy...
Năm 2000 thì có thể nó cũng không có trên này cơ.
Thì...
Cái này chỉ...
Trong mấy chút năm đổ lại thôi.
Thì...
Dụ như cái...
Mình xem mà cái status ở đây.
Nếu mà nó đã active.
Nghĩa là cái đấy...
Nó đang tăng.
Còn tất cả những cái này là trước đấy.
Thì mình sẽ ấn vào cái số MLS.
Thì...
Trong đấy...
Đây là một cái trang rất là phổ biến...
Về tất cả những cái thông tin mà nó có.
Thì ví dụ như mình là...
Mình mua chẳng hạn là...
Mình muốn xem thông tin về cái nhà này.
Thì mình sẽ đọc tất cả những cái thông tin ở đây.
Tương tự nếu mình mà...
Người bán nhà này.
Thì khi mà mình đang bán.
Mình cũng sẽ phải điến tất cả những cái thông tin này
ra.
Cho mình hỏi.
Bạn nói tiếp đi.
Tí mình hỏi chung một lần luôn.
Thì nói chung là mình cứ...
Mình cứ nói qua những cái mình hay dùng trước nhé.
Xong rồi...
Có gì thì...
Tất cả những cái thông tin trên này này.
Là...
Đang là trên màn hình đấy nha.
Tất cả những cái này là có trên Zillow.
Nó sang tất cả những trang khác hết.
Cái nhất định ý.
Ví dụ...
Đến cái đoạn...
Private Remarks ở dưới này.
Cái này là cái...
Thì có Agent lên MLS thì mình xem được thôi.
Thì có một số đoạn ở đây là...
Thì có Agent lên MLS mới xem được.
Hoặc là...
Tất cả những cái từ dưới này xuống dưới này.
Cái này cũng là...
Chỉ có Agent lên MLS mới xem được.
Còn nói chung là từ cái...
Public...
Cái Property Description lên tất cả chỗ này.
Thì nó sẽ hiện qua MLS.
Thì...
Dụ như mình là người mua nhá.
Hoặc là kể cả mình không phải là người mua đi.
Mình chỉ muốn tìm hiểu về cái này thôi.
Thì...
Có những cái chat khác bên cạnh này này.
Là những cái này là thông tin MLS nó pull vào.
Thông tin của county, thông tin của county tự đồng thuế cho
mình.
Dụ như chính cái nhà này họ đóng thuế năm 2025, 2024,
2023 bao nhiêu.
Dụ như cái địa chỉ nhà, đây là cái legal description, cái
này nó pull từ trang của public information của county lên luôn.
Thì tất cả những cái owner này, tất cả những cái này
là public information luôn.
Tất cả những cái này cũng là từ public information.
Thì cái tab này nhá, nó giúp mình được một bước là
mình không phải lên cái trang web của city hoặc của county
để mình tìm cái căn này mà nó pull trong này.
Cái tab tiếp theo là hình ảnh nhá, thì họ upload hình
ảnh đây thì mình xem được này.
Cái history là hình ảnh của county.
Cái history này là mình cũng sẽ xem được là history là
history chuyên ở trên MLS.
Là ví dụ nhá, thì ví dụ là cái
căn này họ đăng từ tháng 7 này.
Ở trên Days on Market
Thì thường nó sẽ count
Cái ngày đấy cho mình ở đây
Xong rồi dụ như mình bảo
Nhấn cái địa chỉ của cái nhà này ra
Thì nó có 4 cái listing ở trên đấy
Thì hẳn là cái 3 cái còn lại
Ở dưới này là 3 cái còn lại
Mà trước đấy nó ra lịch sử
Tận hạn năm 22, 24, 25
Cái này nó cũng pull từ public record luôn
Phần còn lại ở dưới này là public record hết
Là trước đấy là giao dịch là chủ nhà
Tên gì bán cho người nào
Vào năm nào xong rồi
Loại ở đây là thường là
Loại bên
Thì nó sẽ bên này có nhiều loại
Loại khác nhau
Thì như kiểu là
Trong gia đình của mình
Mà sang tên
Thì tên của nó là
Một loại đi khác
Còn khi mình bán nhà
Thì mình cũng có thể đọc được
Cái loại đấy ở trên này
Xong rồi
Khi mà public record
Là nhà đấy mà họ có vay tiền
Để mà họ mua hay không
Thì nó cũng có cái mortgage history
Để nó cũng là public record luôn
Thì nó cũng pull vào ngay
Trong cái phần này là
Năm nào
Kể cả cái chủ nhà đấy nhá
Ví dụ
Ví dụ nhá là chủ nhà đấy
Bao nhiêu năm nay vẫn ở đấy
Nhưng mà họ
Họ refinance
Tức là họ lấy một cái mortgage
Nó cũng hiện ở trên này luôn
Mấy lần đây là nó refinance
Rồi nó hiện ở trên này
Đây là refinance
Những cái nhà mà trước đấy
Kiểu bị foreclosure á
Là kiểu họ không trả được tiền
Mà kiểu họ bị nhà banh lấy lại nhà
Thì nó cũng hiện ở trên này luôn
Ok
Thì đấy còn đâu
Mấy cái còn lại
Thì nó khá là đơn giản
Thì thường ấy
Là khi vào một trang
Thì dụ như mình nói
Ban vừa nãy nhá
Là có nhiều cái app
Nó kết nối vào ấy
Thì ở ngay cái hàng dưới cùng
Trên màn hình của mình nhá
Mình thấy BrokerBay
Mình cái Cloud CMA
Thì như vừa nãy mình
Mình hay dùng Quick CMA
Hoặc Cloud CMA
Để mà so sánh nhà này
Với những cái nhà
Lân cận chẳng hạn
Thì mình dùng những cái app
Ở đây luôn
Hoặc là ví dụ như
Mình muốn cái này cho khách
Hoặc là mình muốn in ra
Email các thứ
Thì cái đấy nó khá là bình thường
Cho mình hỏi sơ là
Hồi nãy ở cái trang trước
Là khi mà mình thấy
Mình xếp cái căn 515
Ở cái địa chỉ này nè
Thì là mình sẽ thấy
Nó sẽ có nhiều cái
Là mỗi cái MLS
Nó sẽ represent
Cho mỗi lần cái căn đó
Được sale
Hay là được chuyển ngay trần
Đúng không các bạn
Đúng rồi
Thì bây giờ
Thì mấy là mình
Ví dụ
Đúng rồi
Nói chung là
Thì bây giờ
Nó có
Vừa nãy nó có ra
4 result
Đúng không
Thì đây là 1
1 of 4 này
Thì dự mình ấn
Thằng cái 2
2 of 4 là cái tiếp theo
Trong cái danh sách đấy luôn
Là nó có thể nó tiếp tục
Thì cái này
Là
Và
Listing date
Là đăng hồi
Xong nó close
Vào cuối tháng 12
Và cái này
Hồi đấy họ đã đăng
1 lần
Expire
Có nghĩa là hồi đấy
Họ đăng
Nhưng mà họ chưa bán được
Và mỗi lần đăng như vậy
Thì nó sẽ có 1 cái number khác nhau
Cho mình hỏi
Ở trên cái hệ thống này là
Mình cũng không rõ lắm
Ở Mỹ với Việt Nam
Có gì khác nhau
Thì là
Cái này là
1 cái căn nhà
Thì có thể có nhiều
Bạn agent đăng cùng
1 lúc không hả
Thường thì không được
Ví dụ ý
Theo đúng luật
Thường thì tôi nghĩ
Thì nó có 1 cái gọi là
Listing type
Nghĩa là
Cái
Cái người đấy
Có được exclusive
Để mà sell
Hoặc là có thể
Rent cái nhà đấy ra không
Thì nó có
Nó có cái term đấy
Nhưng mà
Cái term này nói chung
Nó chỉ đại loại
Như kiểu là
Exclusive right to sell
Có nghĩa là cái agent này
Được quyền exclusive
Để bà bán
Nhưng mà kể cả
Phủ nhà
Họ tự tìm được
Người mua chẳng hạn
Thì agent này vẫn được
Thì nói chung là cái term này
Nói chung là
đa số là nó chỉ để giúp bảo là ai là người
được tiền thôi nhưng mà cái quan trọng ở đây là cái
cái system này khi mà mình khi mà mình đăng lên ý
là nó sẽ tự báo là bây giờ nó đang được đăng
ở
một nhà khác hay các thứ thì của một người khác chẳng
hạn thì nó sẽ không cho mình đăng thêm nữa
Vậy là phải là một xp mới có người khác đăng lên
được thì cho mình hỏi là cái quy trình đó tức là
làm
sao để mình một cái người agent biết được là ok
là tôi đang có cái Exclusive right cho căn này hay là
tôi đang hay là một cái trận khác là Exclusive right cho
căn này để tránh trường hợp giảm chừng nhau
đúng rồi đúng rồi thì thì cái này nhanh thì nó chung
là đơn luật pháp với cả quy luật nó vào thì nó
chặt chẽ nghĩa là khi mà mình đăng một cái nhà của
ai đấy là mình phải ký hợp đồng với họ thì nó
có
hẳn một cái form luôn là như kiểu có thể là listing
representation agreement thì trong đấy nó sẽ hỏi là
loại listing của mình là loại gì thì mình sẽ lại đấy
ra xong rồi khi mình đăng cái nhà này là mình cũng
phải biết cái loại đấy của mình là loại gì ra thì
nó chung là mình nó chung là mình phải có hợp đồng
sau này trên này khi mình đang mình phải là phải phải
chuẩn cái đấy với nhau rồi mình mà là người đầu tiên
đang chẳng hạn mình đã có hợp đồng rồi thì ok xong
rồi sau đấy những người mà sau đấy mà muốn xem
chủ nhà này chẳng hạn thì dũng giống như mình mình vừa
làm thôi là mình đang muốn nghiên cứu cái
nhà này hoặc là mình muốn gặp chủ nhà để mình được
bán cái này chẳng hạn thì mình mình điền cái mình tìm
cái địa chỉ nhà ở đây là mình tự biết được là
họ đang có một người khác mà họ đã có exclusive right
to
xeo rồi à à à à à thường là một cái hợp
đồng như vậy là nó kéo dài cho bao lâu hả
muốn biết bao nhiêu bao lâu được đấy là tùy chủ nhà
với cả tùy họ muốn biết bắt đầu được nhưng mà
họ có được dừng giữa chừng không có họ họ biết được
họ họ được bỏ thì họ trong luận như thế họ
sẽ biết ở trong hợp đồng như thế luôn đó là tôi
có thể đơn phương chấm dứt hợp đồng cử đấy
thường cái này không không ai được đơn phương chấm dứt cả
hai bên chấm dứt rất thì nó lại có một
cái form khác họ phải điền là để để gọi là chung
nơi xin lập lý thì họ lại điền cái ra hai bên
cùng điền
với nhau khi mà ví dụ ở đây nhá dụ như như
bản thân mình là mình là bố tờ chẳng hạn thì dụng
cái listing agent ở đây tên là gì xong rồi họ
phải có một cái brokerage thì cái broker của họ là
Coldwell Banker chẳng hạn thì cái cái người thì broker
của họ phải là cái người kéo cái này xuống chứ cái
người
agent cũng không kéo được xuống cơ tức là mình chỉ là
tức là bên này theo kiểu là lời khác nào cũng thế
thế nên là cái người broker bên trên này như kiểu là
Supervisor là người đấy phải phải liên hệ với
mô để mà kéo xuống sẽ đưa cái tên này ra cho
MLS để kéo xuống chứ còn tự agent cũng không làm được
cho mình hỏi thêm là ai sẽ là người phụ trách để
mà khiếp những cái thông tin này up to date ha
chẳng hạn như ok là khi mà một cái hợp đồng nó
expire hay là một cái hợp đồng thì ai sẽ là người
giống như là chuyển những cái status đó hay là đưa một
cái căn nhà lên mls ha thì thì phần lớn nhất từ
cái
việc từ cái việc là kéo hợp đồng xuống kéo listing xuống
thì mình phải liên quan đến broker còn vụ như bản
thân mình chẳng hạn thì Realtor là người phải phải phải
phải lên đây mình trên thằng những cái
information này và luật khá là chặt chẽ theo kiểu là đúng
cho like thằng của mình luôn đi theo luật luôn
ý là nó sẽ đề xuất là trong tất cả những cái
mục là mình phải up đến như nào ví dụ nhá Bây
giờ mình
có thể làm ví dụ là dụ như mình vào một cái
hợp đồng chẳng hạn xong mình có ba ngày tức là 72
tiếng để
mình để để mình thay đổi cái cái xa đấy mình mà
không thay đổi đúng đấy anh khác họ mà biết họ có
thể
mình lên với lên lên với lên lên với association hoặc là
mình có thể bị phạt cái đấy là những tất cả những
cái thông tin đấy là Realtor rất là phải chật chẽ
cho đúng là mình phải tự làm cái đấy thì bây giờ
mình ví dụ cho các bạn bây giờ mình đang có mấy
cái xin có mấy cái xin cái này của mình là mình
đang vừa
đăng vừa để bán và vừa để vừa để thuê thì bạn
có thể thấy ở đây là cái căn này mình vừa đăng
bán và vừa
cho đây là hai cái listing của mình thì ví dụ như
mình chọn một trong hai cái này thì nói chung ấy khi
mình edit với cả khi mình mới điền mới điền mới tinh
thì nó cũng khá là giống nhau thì bây giờ mình dùng
cái ví dụ này để mà các bạn xem được là là
khi mà điền rồi thì chông nó như thế nào ha thì
khi mình
thay đổi mình có thể thay đổi những cái sau residential cái
này là mình sẽ ấn vào là mình từng cái thông
tiền thông tin nhà như thế nào là mình có thể điền
đa số với tất cả những cái thông tin mà là bao
nhiêu
phòng ngủ kích cỡ bao nhiêu có có những tiện nghi gì
các thứ nọ chẳng hạn thì cái đấy mình luôn luôn
biết ở trong đấy là cái người mua và cái agent của
người mua họ họ vẫn phải kiểm tra lại cái này mình
chỉ là mình viết so với cái cái mà mình hiểu biết
hoặc là sao giờ họ cho mình được cái gì thì họ
ấy
có thể không nên một số lúc họ có thể bị nhầm
chẳng hạn hoặc là ví dụ một cái nhà nó đang ở
3 năm
trước nó có thể là được đi học ở cái trường cấp
2 này nhưng mà nhưng mà sau này gần đây nó đổi
trường
chẳng hạn dự đến người sau rồi của mình mà không có
con học trường cấp 2 thì có thể họ không để ý
họ không biết chẳng hạn thì mình vẫn có có một số
trường hợp cũng không phổ biến đâu nhưng mà có thể
thấy ra là có thể vẫn để cái trường cấp 2 cũ
thì ví dụ cái người mua họ thực sự muốn mua nhà
để cho
con mình đi đúng học một cái trường cấp 2 đấy chẳng
hạn thì họ vẫn phải tự tự confirm cái cái cái thông
tin
ở trên này còn đâu bây giờ những cái chỗ này nhớ
tất cả những cái chỗ trên này biết là tất cả cái
này nó sẽ là status hết là tất cả cái này mình
vừa nói luôn là là theo đúng luật là có 72 tiếng
để mà
mình thì nó có thể là active contingency active option contract nó
là một thể loại là mình đang trong
hợp đồng trên suy pending cái này là sau khi họ đã
hết cái option xong thì họ vẫn đang trong hợp đồng
xong rồi dự như active kick out lại dự như làm ai
đang định mua rồi nhưng mà lý do họ không mua
được nữa thì họ có thể lại quay lại active close là
khi mình bán xong rồi mình bán xong mình bán giá
bao nhiêu mình cũng mình cũng cũng bắt buộc là mình phải
để đúng cái giá ở trên này đúng cái giá mình bán
và cái người agent của bên kia tên là gì mình cũng
phải viết rất là cụ thể luôn và cái này là mình
là
cái người cái người của người bán là phải phải có cái
thông tin này
thế nhá xong rồi ở dưới này thì nó cũng đơn giản
hô dự mình có thể đăng hình ảnh này
là upload document ở đây để mọi người xem được này khi
mà mình vào xem đúng cái listing này của
mình nhất thì mình phải đi đến tất cả những cái sát
này khi mà mình khi mình đăng nhà thì ở đây có
giá có
có ngày list này gửi trong hợp đồng của mình cái ngày
hết hạn là ngày bao nhiêu mình cũng phải ghi
vào đây xong mình tận những thông tin này dụ như cái
này cái mấy bạn vừa hỏi là làm thế nào để thể
hiện được là cái người
này là cái người được bán chẳng hạn thì đây nó có
rất nhiều xa ở đây luôn mình sẽ phải chọn một cái
này để ghiền vào
ở bên đấy lúc mà mình đăng một cái listing đấy Thúy
thì họ có một cái gọi là một cái để để data
để
ví dụ bạn thì cần nhập cái địa thị nhà đấy là
nó tự phu ra diện tích nhà rồi xây dựng năm bao
nhiêu
phương phô rồi các kiểu hay là mình phải phê phê bằng
tay hết có có một số trường hợp là mình sẽ
ấy được thì bây giờ ví dụ như mình chẳng vào mình
thao tác và mình làm một cái nhà mới đi thì bây
giờ
từ từ để mình ví dụ nha là mình sẽ lấy đúng
cái số MLS của cái nhà này mình có gì ví
dụ historical
data của cái căn đấy listing cũ của nó là hả thì
nó có full những cái description với cái nhà đấy
nó có auto fill hay nó có vẻ dữ liệu đấy không
hay là anh lại phải nhập lại từ đâu có nó có
đây ca sẵn
thì nhớ mình thức mình vào đây mình vào input là cái
này là như khi mình thiết lập mới mình có thể đi
bởi xe xin hoặc là mình ăn một cái new thì mình
áo như đây mình có thể có nhiều cách khác nhau dùng
như mình bán nhà để ở thì ra residential là cái này
là để mình cho thuê nhà để ở trong có commercial
cái này nữa thì ví dụ mình đang trong cùng mà cái
category là cái nhà kia mình đang ở ấy ha thì
một đấy là nó sẽ ra sống trơn như thế này mình
có thể điền thì ở trên này cái ba cái nút ở
trên này
là ba cách mình có thể lấy cái data ra một đi
làm những có thể khu từ tử tất cái này là thông
tin ở
nhà hàng đầu public database của của county và của city thì
có thể nhà này có thể tax ID thường mọi
người không ai nhớ tax ID của nhà mình đâu thì họ
biển cái địa chỉ nhà ra hoặc là địa chỉ tên chủ
nhà
ra thì nếu mà nó nó kéo được ở trên xách xuống
thì có thể điền vào cái này hay là nếu mà cái
nhà
đấy đã có trên MLS rồi chẳng hạn ấy thì bây giờ
ví dụ nhá mình có cái căn vừa nãy mình vừa copy
cái số MLS
nó sẽ xong kể cả cái số MLS từ bao nhiêu năm
rồi hoặc là nhà này đã chốt từ lâu rồi nhá mình
lấy
số nào cũng được nhưng mà mình mà dùng được cái số
đấy thì nó cũng sẽ cho mình thì đây thì nó có
cái
những cái căn bàn ở đây xong rồi sau đấy mình vẫn
phải biết giá mình vẫn phải những cái mới ra nhưng mà
có những cái điều chỉnh còn những cái thông tin gọi là
phít rồi thì nó nó sẽ có sẵn ở đấy hết rồi
thì
mình sẽ nói đây là thường thường là 60 70 phần trăm
là mình có thể kéo được từ cái số này ra còn
dụng
như đã giống như nhà đa số mọi người mà ở lâu
rồi hoặc là như cử mình bảo là MLS cái database
này
có thể chỉ là chục năm đổ lại mà nó cũ quá
nhà đấy mà không bán không có một cái giao dịch gì
trong
vòng chục năm vừa rồi thì có khi họ cũng không có
MLS number thì mình một số trường hợp là mình phải điền
cái cái anh bảo nghe view cái luồng đăng tin này tức
khi mà đây là mình đăng ký là mình bán cái nhà
đấy gọi là với cái hệ thống MLS này còn sau đấy
thì mình hoàn toàn có thể đi gọi là đăng trên các
cái
nền tảng khác đúng không theo kiểu là Zillow hay là whatever
những cái nền tảng mà mọi người hay dùng
để để bán nhà ấy thì nó tự động đăng từ cái
này lên hay là mình phải sang bên đấy để mình thao
tác
đa số nó tự động à tự động luôn hả từ cái
MLS này nó tự đẩy lên trên Zillow và các nền tảng
khác mình
không cần phải lên đấy và thông tin nó sẽ đồng bộ
với nhau đúng rồi nó đồng bộ luôn dụng như là mà
nó khá là nhanh nhanh ví dụ ví dụ như một cái
căn nhà này của mình mình đang muốn thay đổi giá chẳng
hạn
mình thay đổi giá xong rồi mình chờ vài phút thì mình
lên Zillow nó cũng đã hiện rồi ồ ồ anh gần như
là nó
có update khá là real time đúng rồi đúng rồi à à
à Nhưng mà có một cái nhé cái này theo luật
thôi
nhưng mà cũng ít người dùng áp dụng trong cái listing agreement
của mình với cả cái người bán trải hạn
nhất thì trong đấy nó sẽ có một mục mà cái em
có thể xách ra xong mình không biết bán khác nào có
thể
không thì nó sẽ hỏi ở đây là cái người sau rồi
có đồng ý cho anh của mình đăng đăng cả của họ
lên
những trang những trang quảng cáo như Zillow các thứ không thì
lấy phải một mục họ phải chọn nào thì đa
số mọi người cũng có có thôi có một số có một
số khách chẳng hạn có thể một lý do cá nhân nào
đấy
thì nó sẽ như kiểu là họ không muốn họ hàng biết
được họ đang bán đúng rồi đúng rồi thì thì họ
cũng thể lựa chọn là không thì trên này cũng có một
cái chỗ là mình có thể bảo nó không được đăng lên
rêu cái trang kia nữa mà chỉ làm tôi đang đăng ký
quyền bán đăng ký cái quyền lên bán cái này với
với MLS rồi mà không đăng ra cái nền tảng đúng rồi
đúng rồi mình có một cái này có thể là sẽ giúp
mọi
trang kia này của mình vừa bán và vừa ăn cho thuê
thì nó có thể hiện cả hai nhưng mà một trang như
Zillow chẳng hạn nhé nó chỉ hiện được một trong hai thôi
nên là nó không nó không hiện được vừa bán vừa
mua ở trên Zillow đâu thế nên là nên là cái gì
mình lên trước là cái đấy là nó sẽ hiện trên Zillow
ở trên cái MLS này nó có nhiều cái tab ở phía
trên phết nhở tức là nó có rất nhiều các cái tính
năng
tên tên tên nhiều nhiều cái feature khác nữa em em chắc
là đối với Realtor chắc chỉ chủ yếu là dùng
những cái liên quan đến gọi là lý tinh ngày thôi đúng
không thực ra những cái tab này nó cũng khá là
giống ở nó cũng chỉ là từng đấy thông tin nhưng mà
nó kéo những cái khác nhau thì ví dụ nhá tôi đã
mình
ví dụ là cái người khách ấy hoặc là bản thân mình
mình có một cái nhà cụ thể mình muốn xem đúng không
thì
mình thì mình lên đấy ví dụ lên cái trang search này
thằng hạn đó mình đang muốn residential mà
ở mỗi quýt search thì lựa như là hiểu đang đi tìm
nhà đi mà hiểu chưa biết ở đâu cả nhưng mà nó
làm
đang khoảng giá này các thứ thì họ có thể điền cái
này thì nó kéo ra được mấy chục cái nhà chẳng hạn
thì mình thêm thì cái search này là nó nó cũng dừng
đến đây đã ra thôi nhưng mà kéo cái khác nhau rồi
cái này nó cũng vậy nó sát nó cũng cũng vậy là
nó có thể kéo được là ô giá trị nhà trong một
cái
khu vực thì nó cũng hãy nó được nhiều nhà cùng một
lúc để nó kéo cùng số liệu xong rồi bên thuế cũng
vậy
hết thuế nó có thể nhiều nhà cùng một lúc thì thực
ra tất cả những cái này nó giống hết những cái mình
xem
cái này nó lên trên kia thôi chỉ chẳng qua là nó
thông tin một cái cách khác cũng như ai mà thích thân
tích số liệu thị trường các thứ thì có thể lên đây
dùng cái đấy cái này là dành cho broker là
agent only thôi đúng không đúng rồi đúng rồi tức là nhắc
cái này là một cái một cái bước khác hơn
bình thường họ cũng cũng có thể không có cái cái access
với cái này cho nó phải chạy một cái tưởng họ
tưởng họ tưởng nghĩ là cái này bắt buộc khi bạn đã
làm bây giờ thì bạn bắt buộc phải sử dụng cái này
hay là có quyền lấy chọn tức là nói chung ấy là
để mà để mình thành công với việc mình làm thì mình
có thể tin thì mình phải đây là này trước hết không
phải là MLS đúng rồi cái
này cái access nó
đi theo association Realtor gì ví dụ như mình ở khu Dallas
Fox 1 sản hạn ở đây có tận 45 cái
association khác nhau luôn thì khi mình tham gia cho sưu xe
trên đấy thì mình sẽ được mình trả tiền
hàng tháng từng order một thì sẽ được access với mls cho
tới hỏi một chút là cái chi phí mà mỗi tháng
mà Realtor cần phải trả để xét đến hệ thống này là
bao nhiêu mình ví dụ nha là một năm là hơn 2
.000 đô
một năm hơn 2.000 đô
dạ dạ
dạ
anh bảo ơi
ôi
một năm trả tận 60 triệu hệ thống này anh bảo ơi
ở đâu thời tài cũng bằng em mua căn nhà xong em
trả thơi đất cho nó cũng mấy ngàn
nam hả
em nghĩ em vong về Việt Nam mình chỉ lên chạc về
tầm 10 triệu rồi chúng nó đã khóc rồi ấy
đó thì thì thì cái này cũng là một trong những cái
bí thức xe khá là khá là cao cho với để làm
Realtor nhưng mà như như mình xem đấy là có thể nói
là suốt hết nhưng mà ai cũng phải cần đấy ai cũng
phải mua cho mình hỏi là nếu mà như vậy
thì là cái cái MLS này nó giống như là một cái
sinh của
nó giống số sắp chút luôn có nghĩa là mình sẽ không
được lăng cái tin khác ở trên các hệ thống khác
như Zillow hay Realtor đúng không tức là mình nó hoàn toàn
phụ thuộc vào MLS này còn thấy dụ như
hồi nãy bạn nói là mình có một căn cho thuê và
cái căn mua căn bán nó cùng một địa chỉ thì nó
chỉ là tô là bán thôi nhưng mà mình có được quyền
lên Zillow để mình tạo thêm một cái listing cho thuê
hay không hay là cái đó là không được luôn
Mình thì mình cũng bản thân mình cũng hay dùng Zillow mà
cũng một phần ý là bản thân mình dùng
Zillow chẳng hạn khi mà cho thuê là khách là mình hay
dùng cái Zillow Rental Management cái đấy là
cái giao diện dành cho một Realtor của Zillow luôn á
thì nó cái đấy nó cũng làm được back project cho cho
khách và họ cũng apply được các thứ trên đấy thì mình
cũng rất hay thích dùng về đấy nhưng mà chỉ có một
cái là nếu mà đã đăng bán rồi thì riêng trên Zillow
nó sẽ không hiện nhưng mà mình có thấy được ý là
những cái này nó cũng đăng tất cả các trang ấy thì
mình cũng không biết được lý do mình cũng chưa có nghiên
cứu để biết lý do tại sao nhưng mà ví dụ Zillow
thì nó sẽ nó sẽ chọn cái đầu tiên này dự như
một số
trang của homes.com chẳng hạn thì nó vẫn hiện được cái
rental của mình xong rồi trang Realtor.com thì một số lúc
nó cũng
hiện được cả một trong hai tức là luôn luôn nó chỉ
hiện được một trong hai nhưng mà cái sequence nó
chọn cái nào thì cái đấy là cái mình chưa chưa nghiên
cứu rõ lắm thì mỗi trang nó logic hơi khác nhau một
chút còn những căn đăng bán là mình có được quyền mình
không thông qua MLS mà mình lên những cái trang khác
mình đăng không hả? Đó cái đấy như kiểu cái này gọi
là off market là cái cổ mình không vẫn mình đúng
đúng không? Đúng không? Đúng như kiểu là bán như kiểu Việt
Nam luôn đấy là mình chỉ như kiểu trao điền
trước cửa ai muốn đến thì đến tự xem xong rồi tự
nêm mếp giá với nhau kiểu vậy ạ thì cái đúng kiểu
off
market thì được được phép không ai bắt mình phải cho lên
trên này cả nhưng mà với vì công nghệ số với các
thứ thì thường lên MLS mình sẽ được quảng cáo nhiều
nhất và kiểu qua được các trang nên là thường mọi
là các trang xem được nhiều nhất thì nên là dụ như
mình là Realtor chẳng hạn khi mà mình bán hàng bán
nhà giúp cho khách thì mình cũng luôn khuyên khách là nên
cho lên mls để mà được có cái quả bán toàn diện
Bên Mỹ, những role của ngành
này bao gồm các lớp nào?
Rồi, lớn nhất là agency.
Rồi, lớn nhất là National Association.
Ok, thì thực ra cái này nó có khá là nhiều thì
mình có thể gửi cho.
Nhưng mà nó khá là nhiều những cái tổ chức khác nhau
nhé.
Thì cái đầu tiên là cái mà nó nằm ở DC, để
ra luật nó gọi là TREC.
TREC thì cái đấy nó, đấy là cái, đấy là như kiểu
governing body, là như kiểu họ viết luật, viết form và kiểu
ra luật luôn cho các lớp.
Bộ xây dựng, anh bảo đấy, bộ xây dựng.
Ok.
Thì họ có cái đấy.
Thì như kiểu, như là cái MLS này nó vẫn kiểu là
optional ấy, như kiểu là mình, mình có thể làm real estate
mà mình không trên MLS ấy.
Thì cái NAR ấy, nó cũng là optional.
NAR là nó, như kiểu nó không liên quan đến chính phủ.
Nó chỉ là, nó gọi là National Association, cứ vậy thôi.
Nhưng mà nó có thể ra một số form riêng của nó
nữa.
Nhưng mà, dù như một số form riêng của nó hoặc là
MLS như thế này thì mình phải, mình phải trả membership một
năm như vậy thì mình mới được dùng và mình mới được
tham gia vào NAR.
Vậy trong NAR ấy, từng bang ấy nó có cái khác nhau.
Thì như kiểu trong này của mình ấy, mình chỉ ra, tham
gia cái tổ chức gần nhất của mình thôi là nó, nó
chỉ là NAR Texas thôi ấy.
Ừ.
Mà nó cũng có cái body khác nữa.
Ừm.
Rồi là cái mà, cái phần mà cái, những cái phần mà
đi bán á, thì nó sẽ có là, nó gọi là Broker
là cao nhất đúng không?
Tức là, ví dụ như một cái đơn vị mà có được
quyền bán những cái bất động sản, thì là cái, cái tầng
cao nhất sẽ là Broker.
Thì bây giờ mình, ví dụ nhá, ví dụ ấy là, nó
chung là môn bán thì bao giờ cũng có giữ giá to
nó liên quan đến luật pháp đúng không?
Ừm.
Thì ví dụ ấy, nếu mà trong một trường hợp đó, nó
trường hợp làm làm ăn mà không không minh bạch hoặc là
cái gì đấy có thể kiện nhau đâu có chứ
ai có thể kiện ai cũng có kính mấy muốn thể kiện
broker hoặc là bán thì kiện broker hoặc là hai
bước của hai bên kiện nhau chung là ai mà kiện nhau
chẳng hạn thì thường họ sẽ kiện worker chứ
họ không không kiện Realtor thì những người như mình như
kiểu là realtor chẳng hạn ấy là mình phải trả
một cái phí cho broker của mình để mình làm việc dưới
broker của mình với điều kiện là như kiểu là
như kiểu là mình được bảo vệ bảo vệ là nếu mà
có ai kiện mình hay là có cái gì đấy chẳng hạn
thì
broker nó sẽ nó nó người ta sẽ bị kiện hoặc là
người ta sẽ bảo vệ mình nhưng mà cũng ngược lại
là broker như nó hơi giống kiểu là vừa là kiểu mentor
vừa là supervisor một chút ý một là bởi
vì họ biết là họ bè các
cái cái cái cái cân nặng về vấn đề kiểu pháp ý
ấy thế nên là tất cả những cái form tất cả những
cái
giao dịch của mình chẳng hạn là họ kiểm tra những cái
đấy hết thì một phần ý là mình trả tiền cho
broker để mình trao bằng mình ở đấy làm với họ chẳng
hạn thì họ cũng sẽ kiểm tra giấy tờ từng
cái giao dịch của mình luôn để make sure là mình sẽ
không bao giờ bị kiện thì sẽ có một bộ phận là
chuyên làm kiểu legal transaction như vậy và thứ hai nữa là
ai mà làm broker mà một số lúc tham
ra một số
một số mà mình không biết là mình làm đúng hay sai
cũng có thể gọi định cho broker của mình để mình hỏi
Thì cái đấy là cái để những công báo vậy nhau còn
đâu broker với Thì nó nó chỉ khác một cái là có
thể
kinh nghiệm cũng đưa hoặc nó cũng một cái bằng thêm Ví
dụ như là mình của bằng Realtor chẳng hạn
mà cũng lên broker cũng có thể lấy một cái bằng em
để lên broker mà cũng sẽ lên broker hết á tưởng ý
là
Mình đã qua bằng và mình có đủ cái giáo dục để
mình được lên broker được
Không có nghĩa là mình cần phải làm broker có nghĩa là
mình phải có công ty riêng
Mình không cần phải như thế, mình vẫn có thể
Dù như ngày mai chẳng hạn mình mà muốn đi team mình
muốn làm broker
Mình vẫn có thể làm broker và mình vẫn có thể ngồi
dưới cái broker
Bây giờ mình làm mình vẫn có thể làm thế được
Nhưng mà một khi được danh broker thì kiểu là mình có
nhiều xét nghiệm về pháp lý hơn
Thì đấy thì ví dụ như trong này chẳng hạn
Trong listing của mình, mình ở đây nhé
Thì đây là listing của mình này
Thì dù như mình có tên ở đây xong rồi mình có
tên của broker của mình
eXp Realty chẳng hạn
Thì khi mà làm giao dịch thì họ sẽ liên hệ với
tên của mình
Xong rồi có số điện thoại các thứ ở đây
Xong rồi mình có supervisor của mình ở đây
Thì thường người này là cái người broker trong brokerage của mình
Thì cái người này cũng như có assign sẵn trong broker của
mình
Là họ chuyên làm broker
Ở trong Texas
Tại vì công ty của mình là công ty international chẳng hạn
Thì đấy thì Karen sẽ là người supervisor
Thì nếu mà ai đấy mà có một cái vấn đề gì
về mình
Họ có thể gọi điện cho broker của mình
Còn đâu đây là có số điện thoại các thứ này nó
của brokerage
Cho mình hỏi thêm là
Không có sự khác biệt giữa Realtor với Real Estate Agent đúng
không?
Là hai cái đó là làm một đúng không?
Đúng!
Mình nói là người bình thường thì mọi người sẽ dùng hai
cái hơi giống nhau
Nhưng mà như mình bảo ấy ai mà tham gia NAR hoặc
là tham gia những cái Realtor Real Estate Association ấy
Thì họ phải tham gia cái đấy và họ phải trả cái
phí hàng năm đấy thì họ mới được gọi là Realtor
Còn không họ chỉ là Real Estate Agent thôi
Thì theo đúng definition của nó như thế
Definition
Ok
Và hình như
ESP này như là một cái
Cái công ty mà nó rất là
Lớn
lấy chi phí thấp đó thực ra là cũng có nhiều cũng
có nhiều nhiều broker khác nhau nhưng mà nhưng mà cũng
có thể một phần là có nhiều cách mọi người chọn broker
của mình có thể một số người broker của dư đưa ví
dụ nhé
mình chọn mình chọn exp bởi vì họ là cái business model
của họ là International của họ online thì
mình chạy phí bàn ví dụ như đúng không đúng văn phòng
có bàn có bàn ghế có thuê chứ không phải physical
thì nó đặt được chi phí ừ ừ ừ ừ
cái ví dụ đây là khi mình đăng bán này thì khi
mà mình hoàn thành giao dịch ấy mà mình sang tên được
cho
người mua người bán với nhau xong rồi thì sao đấy có
phải quay lại cái này mình update là tôi đã bán với
cái giá bao nhiêu rồi giao dịch vào ngày nào số hợp
đồng có thứ như nào không có nhá thì ví dụ
Bắt buộc, bắt buộc tại vì mình đã bán rồi mà cái
người, đấy là nhiệm vụ của cái người listing agent nhá.
Nghĩa là họ đã bán cái này rồi mà họ vẫn để
active ở trên này thì đấy là lỗi của họ.
À và có thể bị phản vì việc đó.
Ví dụ mình vào cái close listing của mình đúng không thì
mình có bao nhiêu cái close đây chẳng hạn thì mình sẽ
cố tình chọn một cái là mình làm người giúp
người mua chẳng hạn.
Thì ví dụ cái này mình bảo vệ người mới mua chẳng
hạn thì đây là tất cả những cái thông tin họ ấy
xong.
Thì sau lúc thông tin xong ấy, khi mà người listing agent
bên kia họ phải update là contract này bao nhiêu, head option
này bao nhiêu.
Tức là cái này là system nó tự note lại khi mà
cứ mỗi lần mình đổ status ấy là nó sẽ ấy.
Xong cái ngày close là ngày bao nhiêu, họ viết vào đấy
giá bao nhiêu.
Xong rồi ví dụ seller mà cho bao nhiêu tiền chẳng hạn
thì họ phải viết vào trong này.
Xong rồi...
Về eXp Realty mình là người agent này thì họ phải viết
ra đây.
Email của mình như thế này.
Họ dùng title company nào họ cũng phải viết.
Xong rồi ví dụ như khách của mình có mortgage hay là
trả bằng tiền mặt chẳng hạn thì nó cũng phải viết ở
đây.
Và cái này ở đây là cái nó sẽ vào record là
khi mà mình bán xong thì nó bán bao nhiêu tiền per
square feet.
Như kiểu là 1m2 ở Việt Nam mình bao nhiêu tiền ấy.
Ờ cái này mình vẫn thấy, Thúy bảo là ghi cả kiểu
như hoa hồng ở đấy luôn à.
Hoa hồng của Realtor ở đấy luôn à.
Hoa hồng thì không nằm trên này, hoa hồng nó không bao
giờ nằm trên này luôn.
Cái đấy là tự, tự điều với nhau.
Ồ.
Ừ.
Tự điều với nhau thì nhớ họ đưa kiểu cash về tiền
ngoài và nó là 1 cái hình thức lách thuế thì sao?
Ờm...
Cái đấy nó có phổ biến không?
Ở Việt Nam thì nó rất phổ biến ấy.
Ở Việt Nam thì nó gần như là nó không ai đóng
thuế gì cái đấy luôn ấy.
Nhưng mà mình nói hỏi ở Mỹ thì nó có như vậy
không?
Tại vì ở bên Mỹ cái này nó...
Nó không phổ biến bởi vì ấy, trả tiền ở đây là
thực ra là trả cho broker.
Xong broker phải trả tiền...
Trả qua công ty, xong rồi công ty mới trả lại cho
mình.
Đúng rồi, đúng rồi. Thế nên là broker để mà nó luôn
luôn làm cho pháp lý.
Thế nên là kiểu gì họ cũng sẽ phải trên đấy thôi.
Tức là tự điều với nhau nhưng mà điều với nhau ở
đây vẫn là trong contract ấy.
Điều với nhau đây là cái...
Rồi, rồi, rồi.
Mình không biết nhưng mà chỉ the rest of the world doesn't
know.
Ah ha ha. Ok, ok.
Còn đâu ấy, tất cả những cái broker nhá, những cái công
ty title company này.
Bên này là cái công ty nằm ở giữa họ, họ cầm
tiền đúng không?
Ok.
Dù như là họ seller lấy lại tiền bao nhiêu, buyer trả
bao nhiêu,
tất cả những agent được trả bao nhiêu tiền là cái công
ty title company họ làm.
Thì bên này họ sẽ cần phải có contract của mình cực
kỳ rõ ràng.
Bao, ai, bao nhiêu hoa hồng thì lúc đấy họ mới trả.
Uhm, uhm, uhm, uhm.
Uhm.
Anh bảo hỏi tiếp đây, anh bảo ơi, có nội dung gì
hả?
Uhm.
dùng cho nhà mình này thì có một cái nó gọi là
khá cma nha thì cái này mình cũng hay dùng tại vì
cái
này thì có thể sử dụng ở Việt Nam này như kiểu
là mọi người nói là mua nhà bao nhiêu các thứ thế
nào
ấy từ từ từ về giá đúng đúng rồi đúng rồi nhẹ
thì cái này nhớ mình cái cực kỳ hay dùng luôn
thì đây là cái trước đấy mình làm cho khách của mình
thì bây giờ mình sẽ lấy một ví dụ cụ thể nhanh
cái list hẳn hoi thì mình hôm nay mình đang cần kéo
lại số liệu cho khách xem thì mình sẽ cho lên đây
thì mình ra report CMA cái này là mình vừa có thể
dùng nó chung là vừa cho người bán cho người mua cho
ai cũng được chung là ai cũng cần làm cái này để
mình biết được là mình mình nên trả giá bao nhiêu ấy
thì
bây giờ mình cho địa chỉ của cái nhà cái nhá thì
cái cái cái CMA này nó có CMA thì cái concept của
nó là có lâu rồi và cái thu của nó cũng có
rất là nhiều mình nhớ là hồi đấy mình mua nhà cách
cách đây
6-7 năm thì hồi đấy chứ có cái Cloud CMA này
thì các CMA này là tìm đến mình sẽ chỉ cho là
nó tự
tự suggest được là bao nhiêu nhà xung quanh mình các thứ
là nó tự suggest được còn đâu có cái CMA là
cái này trên này nó khá là lâu rồi như kiểu là
mình phải tự lên mình phải tự tìm trong database để
mình so sánh thì cái đấy là cái cũ hơn đây là
cái mới hơn thì nó rất là nhanh thì
nhà này là nhà của khách mình nhé mình ngay thì nó
tìm thấy số thông tin của tax nó phải tự hiện lên
nhưng mà đa số của mình mình cũng phải tự cho so
sánh vào là nhà này bao nhiêu phòng ngủ 4 phòng ngủ
phòng tắm cái này là đúng rồi xong rồi mình có thể
viết report đây là tôi hiếu hay xong rồi mình có
hình ảnh đây là chứ là một cái report thì cái ở
dưới này nếu mà mình muốn tìm một số so sánh chỉ
là
để giúp mình là mình biết nhà cụ thể mình muốn so
sánh rồi mình chỉ muốn cho report trên report cho
mình chẳng hạn thì mình có thể đánh hàng số mls vào
đây nhưng trong tình hợp này là mình mình chưa biết
tìm mình chỉ muốn tìm không thì khi mà mình với sức
chẳng hạn thì mình có thể thay đổi là mình muốn
kéo tất cả những cái nhà đã bán trong vòng bao nhiêu
thời gian đấy chẳng hạn thì tùy mình thì
dự mình chọn một năm và mình chỉ cần muốn 10 cái
thôi dụ một số lúc mà nhà rất là khó tìm một
cái nhà
tương tự chẳng hạn thì có thể mình sẽ lên ba 20
30 cái nhà nhưng mà ví dụ là mình chọn tay nhé
mình không mình cũng có thể hiện lên mình cũng có thể
biết vào đây thì bây giờ mình sẽ tương giản nhé
là mình không biết vào đây thì để nó hiện những cái
gì thì nó sẽ tự chọn cho mình 10 cái căn nhà
mà
đã bán gần đây sẽ hiện lên là cái nhà của mình
đang đang hỏi là cái nào ta một góc này thì nó
biết được
địa chỉ nào ở đâu thì nó cố tình là kéo những
cái nhà xung quanh và trong cái của mình là phải bán
trong vòng một năm vừa rồi nó hiện lên là đây có
bao nhiêu cái active bao nhiêu cái xô ở đây xong rồi
nó sẽ tự tự tính cho mình cái này khi đấy là
cái công việc của agent của mình nghĩ là mình phải tự
tìm
xem cái căn nào nó phù hợp với cái của mình ví
dụ như cái đã expired mình không bao giờ mình cũng đã
không
thường thường mình không so sánh vì những cái này đi kiểu
là họ không bán được thế nên là cái số của
họ nó không không tốt đấy thì mình những cái khô là
những cái mà đã bán rồi thì mình có thể bảo mình
xem thì đây đây cái tổ history record nó sẽ giúp mình
như kiểu là bây giờ mình muốn so sánh nhà
nhưng mình cũng muốn là xem trong nhà ấy nó có tương
đương với cái giá trị của mình như là họ cũng
những cái gì cũng tốt hay không chẳng hạn mình xem xong
rồi xong rất là những cái feature này cũng
có thì mình cũng so sánh cái này là đô tờ thôi
thì ví dụ như nhà mình một tầng chẳng hạn thì system
nó không biết nó không kéo được là một tầng hay hai
tầng nó sẽ luôn kéo cả hai chẳng hạn thì dụ như
nhà mình đang một tầm thì cái này một tầng mà ok
này nhưng mà ví dụ mình xem nhà của mình xây 2023
như nhà này là xây 2010 thì nó tranh lệch nhau quá
nên là mình không chọn cái nhà này nữa hay
xây 2029 mình cũng không chọn nhà này xây 2022 nó khá
là gần với nhà của mình có vẻ như nhà này
hai tầng đúng không nhà hai tầng thì không thể so sánh
với nhau được bởi vì nó nó hơi khập khiễng nhưng
mà nó cũng sẽ hiện những cái thông tin cụ thể đây
on market là bao nhiêu ngày họ ở trên thị trường thì
giờ mình hay dùng cái này để mình biết được thêm xem
là cái đi men ở đấy như thế nào tôi là họ
bán
như thế này khá là chậm họ bất chừng ngày ngày để
họ bán khá là chậm nên mình mình mà thấy nhiều nhà
cùng cái khu đấy đều có cái số liệu như thế thì
mình biết được cái đi men của cái khu nhà đấy xong
rồi
tức là họ bán ngày nào họ các thứ ví dụ như
bên này của mình ý là mùa hè là thường cái mùa
gia đình và
con cái nghỉ học thì họ hay hay chuyển nhà hơn ý
thì mình cũng thể xem là cái ngày họ bán là mùa
nào trong
năm nó cũng có thể ảnh hưởng giá của mình mình cũng
có thể xem cái nhá thì cái này hai tầng mình bỏ
đi này
cái này hoặc một số cái khác dụ như nhà này nhá
cũng hai ngàn hai mươi tư thì mình cũng bỏ rồi này
nhưng mà cái số lượng bedroom về bathroom hoặc là cái quay
phía mà nó chênh quá thì mình cũng không
chọn nhưng mà đấy tại loại là mình có thể xem nó
thu tất cả các nhà luôn thường như cái nhạc đang
ách tích chẳng hạn thì mình đây là chính nhà của mình
luôn là này là cái nhà này thì nó cũng tự
hiện lên hoặc là hàng xóm cũng đang bán về giá cao
hơn thẳng hạn nhiều lúc cái cái này mình cũng
không hay dùng để mà so sánh giá đâu bởi vì họ
chưa bán đúng hơn bên này là mình chỉ so sánh những
căn đã bán rồi thôi đã bán được thì lúc đấy mình
mới dùng cái số liệu đấy để mà phân tích cái giá
xung quanh ý còn bao nhiêu nhà đang bán chẳng thì mình
đi cường mình biết là mình đang cạnh thanh với những
nhà này cái nhà này như vậy thôi thì mình xem cái
này còn đâu nhớ mình cứ đang ví dụ
Ừ thực ra mình cũng không có quá nhiều nhà trong khu
này để mà so sánh thì mình sẽ phải xem thử
căn này căn này một tầm Ok các này comparable thì
ví dụ mình chọn cái căn này để mình compare nhá
thường là mình sẽ phải chọn mấy nhà không thường mình chọn
một nhà là cũng chưa comparable cho lắm
mình muốn có một cái phu của nhiều nhà để nó ra
được cái thì mình sẽ chọn cái đấy
cái này hai tầng một số lúc mà không tìm được thì
mình lại expand ra là muốn nó suggest 20 nhà 30 nhà
hoặc là mình phải expand cái thời gian này nhưng cứ ví
dụ như là mình cái nhà mình muốn rồi thì mình
có thể trên cái report ấy ừ ừ ừ ừ
Ừ
thì trong này mình có thể chọn rất là nhiều thứ là
mình có muốn introduction về bản thân mình không
dùng dụ như mình muốn gửi một khách nào chẳng hạn ấy
thì mình có thể cho cover letter tất cả những
cái này what is CMA mình cũng có thể giải thích cái
đấy với họ nếu mình muốn thì họ có tên cái này
một cái này giống như là nguyên một cái sắp đi bọt
PDF để gửi cho một khách hàng đúng không đúng
đúng không cái này sẽ ra được thằng luôn ạ thì cái
này là một số chính họ muốn là mình nói thêm mình
education họ hay các thứ này nọ thì mình muốn thêm vào
thì mình cho thêm nhá thì này nó chung là cái
thua là full sẵn thường thì mình chọn sẵn rồi rồi mình
hay dùng thì mình bảo là mình chỉ muốn nó thể
hiện là cái mát là ở đâu xong rồi cho thêm cái
hình ảnh để họ xem được cho mình muốn ở đây là
họ mình
cho mình cho mình cái cái price per square footage ở đây
thì mình chọn cái đấy nhất từ mình chọn từ
bên trái này mình cho sang bên phải là cái mình muốn
nó cho cho mình thì mình ra được cái report
cho mình hỏi là cái Cloud CMA này là
mình phải là Realtor thì mình mới và mình phải đăng
ký nó nói
cái chung cái này là cùng một cái gói mình trả hàng
năm luôn đúng không là nó sẽ có rồi rồi nó có
mấy cái áp nhỏ mà nãy mà bạn nói đúng không đúng
rồi đúng rồi nó nó cùng mấy cái đấy luôn
thì đúng ra em không biết nó bố là nó nó có
cái khuyết CMA sẵn cái Cloud CMA này như là một cái
cái app thêm để nó nó phê hơn thôi thì dựng cái
này là cái cân bản nhá mình mà muốn đẹp hơn mình
có
thể làm thì mình có thể lấy thông tin của mình nó
tự hiện ra thông tin của mình luôn nó hiện ra là
hai
cái này mình đang so sánh hẳn như thế này nó đều
4 phòng 3 phòng tắm và square footage là hơi chênh
cái này nó gặp nhau một chút thì thì mình đang so
sánh hai cái đấy thì cái căn căn mình vừa xem là
nó average nó ra được là 209 dollar per square
feet xong rồi sau đấy nó sẽ hiện ra cái căn này
như thế nào
đây là cái thông tin MLS của cái căn cũ đấy nhá
là họ họ bán như đây John Market họ có những thông
tin
cái gì tất cả nó hiện ở đây rồi mình là muốn
thêm hình ảnh thường mình hay cho khách để xem hình ảnh
để so sánh nhà xong rồi ví dụ mình mà có nhiều
nhà nhất như còn mình chọn nhiều cái thì nó sẽ có
average là
cái mình thường chọn 3 cái nhà đi là nó nằm trong
lên sẽ như thế nào nó sẽ biết ở đây xong rồi
xong rồi
thì nó cũng ra được một số cái sát này ừ ừ
ừ ừ ừ ừ ừ ừ ừ ừ ừ
đấy thì nó cũng ra được average 2 square feet nó chung
là cái này là cái khá là mình mình cái này phải
là khá
là sức khô kiểu khách của mình dễ hiểu dễ tập thì
mình thường cho mấy cái trang này còn mình muốn thêm
dâu kia là mình có thể chọn vào để nó ra cái
mình mình mình hiểu này cũng chi tiết phát
đó thì nó chung là đấy là cái từ nãy giờ là
cái cái mình hay dùng xong mọi người có câu hỏi gì
không
mình thì chắc cũng hết câu hỏi rồi mình có câu hỏi
gì không phải bình chạm thời thì em chưa có cảm ơn
mọi người
Ok.
Cho mình hỏi là những cái app hồi nãy lúc ban đầu
mà bạn giới thiệu là thường là những cái app đó nó
chỉ là exclusively cho cái khu vực Texas này thôi hay là
những cái ví dụ như Realtor ở các bang khác nó cũng
sẽ là cùng những cái app giống giống như vậy hả?
Ờ đúng rồi. Thường cái giao diện nó khác nhau thôi nhưng
mà ở đâu cũng có hết á.
Ví dụ như, ở đâu cũng có hết rồi.
Như cái RentSpree là cái mà mình bảo là mình có
thể screen tenant chẳng hạn là nó cũng có thể ở đây.
BrokerBay là cả. Nói chung cái app này đều là kiểu cả
nước dùng hết.
Tức là bạn ví dụ mình làm đối tòa ở Texas nhưng
mà mình hoàn toàn có thể lên những cái hệ thống này
để mình search.
Hay là báo cáo report ở những cái khu vực như bang
khác như Maryland, Boston đúng không?
Hay là nó chỉ exclusively cho Texas.
Về những cái thông tin available ấy thì nó như kiểu, như
kiểu anh biết là mỗi bang là nó có cái database riêng
đúng không?
Thì như kiểu mình ở Texas mình chỉ xem được Texas và
quanh đây thôi.
Nhưng mà tất cả những cái app hoặc những cái data hoặc
những cái field nào mà mình có thể xem được,
thì thực ra cả nước nó cũng rất là giống nhau.
Đúng thôi, nó chỉ có giao diện khác nhau thôi.
Kể cả thực ra mình vào một giao diện khác nó cũng
khá là khó dùng
bởi vì là có thể nút này nó bên trái, nút kia
nó ở một cái tab khác xong mình phải đi tìm ấy.
Thì cái đấy là cái learning curve về cái việc mình xem
nó ở đâu thôi nhưng mà thông tin available nó khá là
giống nhau.
Ok.
Và nếu mà mình là Realtor ở Texas, mình có được quyền
bán nhà ở bang khác không?
Cái đấy là bởi vì lý do pháp lý mình không được.
Không được.
Bởi vì là mỗi bang nó có thể ra luật khác nhau.
Đấy là bởi vì cái luật, dụ như TREC chẳng hạn, bộ
xây dựng không, nó chỉ ra,
khi mà mình làm contract các thứ nó chỉ ra cho mình
form nó ra cho mình mười mấy form gì đấy.
Cái đấy dùng chung cả nước.
Còn đâu ý, mỗi bang nó khác nhau lắm.
Mình có thể làm những cái form khác mà như kiểu là
Texas Association of Realtors thẳng hạn là phải viết cái form riêng
bởi vì là cái market nó khác nhau.
Ví dụ nhá, mình chỉ ví dụ thôi vì cái market nó
cũng khác nhau.
Ví dụ như là ở Texas có nhiều dầu mỏ các thứ
đúng không?
Thì khi mà mình mua bán nhà ấy, nhiều lúc người ta
cũng quan tâm đến dầu mỏ ở dưới cái mảnh đất mình
ấy.
Thì nó cũng sẽ có thêm một số luật chẳng hạn.
Hoặc là một số bang như Florida mà nó gần biển chẳng
hạn, nó bị lụi.
Ừ.
Các thứ nhiều chẳng hạn thì nó cũng có thêm một số
luật của nó ấy.
Thì một là vừa về cái knowledge của mình về từng cái
market nó khác nhau.
Với hai là bang đấy nó tự viết được luật của họ.
Thế nên là nó cũng khá là khác nhau.
Nếu vậy thì ví dụ một Realtor có thể là mình giống
như có bằng ở nhiều bang mà mình hoạt động ở nhiều
bang được hay không?
Hay là luật pháp chỉ cho mình hoạt động ở một bang
thôi?
Được. Là mình có thể xin bằng nhiều bang.
Ở phía Bắc chẳng hạn, ví dụ như là New Hampshire nó
gần với Massachusetts.
Có thể một số Realtor là họ ở border đấy là có
thể họ lấy cả hai bang.
Hoặc là cái common khác như kiểu là North Carolina và South
Carolina thì có thể mọi người sẽ lấy hai bằng chẳng hạn
ấy.
Thì họ cũng ấy được nhưng mà mỗi bang họ phải làm,
họ phải ký với một broker riêng và họ phải trả tiền
để vào MLS khác nhau.
Thế nên là cái cost đấy nó sẽ nhân đôi.
I see, I see.
Hiếu ơi, em có câu hỏi gì không?
Anh thì chắc cũng hòm hòm hết câu hỏi rồi đó Hiếu
ơi.
Em nghĩ là mình như vậy là cũng chiếm dụng thời gian
của Thúy lâu phết rồi đấy.
Có gì, không có gì.
Nói chung là giúp được gì thì giúp thôi.
Thì công ty của Hiếu là như kiểu mình đang làm project.
Để mình muốn thiết kế cho bên bộ hay sao?
Tức là cái giai đoạn này thì không biết là Thúy có
để ý không thì ở Việt Nam hiện nay cái chuyển đổi
số nó rất là mạnh mẽ ở trong chính phủ với cả
nhà nước.
Thì bộ xây dựng cũng đang làm một cái dự án chuyển
đổi số như vậy.
Thì cái đấy thì tất nhiên là bên trong bộ thì họ
sẽ không có nguồn nhân lực để có thể làm rồi.
Đấy thì bên mình là bên thầu lại cái mảng đấy ở
bộ xây dựng để triển khai một cái hệ thống thông tin.
Về data. Đấy sau đấy thì những cái nhiều MLS này thì
nó có thể là những cái layer ở phía trên để ra
thị trường.
Nếu làm xong cái này thì mình nghĩ là cái dữ liệu
nó cũng sẽ được tương tự như ở Mỹ đấy.
Đấy bây giờ thì đang đi làm sạch dữ liệu đất đai
ở trên cả nước rồi.
Tức là chuyển đổi từ như có database ở trong bộ là
như kiểu là những nhà đang existing ở ngoài kia.
Là bây giờ mình cũng đi lấy hết số liệu.
Đúng không?
Đúng rồi. Đúng rồi.
Và thực ra từ trước đến giờ ví dụ cái mua bán
bất động sản ở Việt Nam ấy thì nó rất là thô
sơ.
Đấy ví dụ bạn đăng một cái tin lên thì nó sẽ
không bao giờ là tin chuẩn cả.
Không có ai xác thực đấy là nó là tin đúng.
Nó không có một hệ thống như ở MLS để đồng bộ
về dữ liệu.
Còn người ta thế là chính vì như thế cho nên người
ta còn không có intention để đăng thông tin thật cơ.
Tại vì đăng thông tin thật thì khách đến tự gặp chủ
nhà luôn thì môi giới chả để làm gì cả.
Cho nên là họ còn đăng thông tin cố tình đăng sai
lệch đi.
Để họ có giá trị về cái việc là dẫn khách đến
gặp chủ nhà và chốt được cái giao dịch đấy.
Và nó cũng sẽ không có những cái quyền lợi để bảo
vệ người môi giới ở giữa.
Đấy.
Chứ là ở trong một cái thị trường mà nó đang chưa
centralized lại về dữ liệu thì mọi thứ nó làm việc nó
rất là căn bản và nó rất là manh mún.
Đấy thì hiện nay cái đề án này nó giúp cho thị
trường là nó có chuẩn hóa được về dữ liệu và nó
sẽ giúp cho thị trường nó minh bạch hơn.
Đấy theo cái định hướng trước đây của Mỹ hay là...
Đấy theo cái định hướng trước đây của Mỹ hay là Trung
Quốc họ đang triển khai rồi.
Ok.
Như kiểu hôm trước Hiếu bảo là...
Như kiểu người khác có thể lên đây để mà xem login
được không ấy.
Thì ví dụ cái đó nhá.
Là bên đó ấy.
Nó khá là cụ thể.
Ví dụ chỉ là mình đăng cái địa chỉ nhà của mình
lên thôi.
Nhưng mà ví dụ như street chẳng hạn là mình spell it
out là street.
Hoặc là mình là st chẳng hạn.
Mình chỉ viết một trong hai cái đấy mà không đúng chuẩn
của MLS ấy.
Đấy luôn hả?
Đấy luôn.
Mình spell reminder là quả bị lộn lên đi.
Rất là chật chẽ.
Xong họ remind mà hai lần mà không ấy là có thể
sẽ bị tán.
Hoặc là...
Hoặc là bởi vì nó rất là nghiêm miết về vấn đề
là...
Là một là bằng cấp của mình số bao nhiêu đúng không?
Broker của mình là gì?
Ví dụ nhá là...
Chỉ là typo thôi.
Dụ như là mình...
Mình bán một căn này mình bán là 699 chẳng hạn.
Nhưng mình ghi là 698 chẳng hạn.
Và một trong ai đấy có trong transaction của mình mà họ
phát hiện ra mình viết sai.
Họ cũng có được sắp explain lên với TREC.
Và mình cũng có thể bị revoke cái license của mình.
Thì...
Yeah.
Thì thế nên là...
Là nó khá là chật chẽ kiểu như vậy.
Thế nên là vừa...
Vừa là luật pháp nó cũng vào để mà...
Để mà niêm yết để mọi người phải theo luật.
Với cả hai nữa là...
Là trong market mọi người cũng nhiều lúc cũng tự...
Bởi vì...
Nó cũng ảnh hưởng đúng không?
Vì tất cả những cái database này nó cũng ảnh hưởng đến
mình hết.
Ví dụ nhá.
Ví dụ như...
Như là...
Ai đấy cần tìm agent chẳng hạn.
Thì muốn xem là bản thân mình...
Là có bán được nhiều nhà không hay các thứ chẳng hạn.
Thì họ cũng có thể lên...
Lên trang Realtor.com chẳng hạn.
Để tìm tên của mình.
Tìm review à?
Một là review.
Hai là nó cũng hiện được history.
Trên những cái căn mình đã show luôn.
Trên iOS nó cũng...
Trên căn nó cũng hiện được...
Những cái thông tin hết luôn.
Ok ok.
Thế là check check để xem realtor nào tốt.
Để mình tìm rồi giúp mình tìm nhà hay đúng không?
Kiểu dạng như vậy.
Ừm.
Thế nên ý.
Bởi vì cái lý do đấy.
Ví dụ như mình mà bán được một cái nhà...
Đắt tiền hoặc là...
Bất cứ cái lý do nào đấy.
Ai đấy mà...
Viết thông tin sai về bản thân mình.
Cũng cảm thấy là mình phải...
Mình phải correct cái đấy.
Để mà nó hiện đúng cái thông tin của mình.
Ừm.
Ở bên này ông Nghiêm ngọt thế chứ.
Hôm trước là...
Mấy lúc đầu là đang nghĩ là nhờ Thúy để xin cái
account để tự login vào và tự xem.
Đấy.
Nhưng mà sau khi là thấy mọi thứ nó nghiêm ngọt như
thế.
Thì là mới nhờ cái buổi như thế này.
Thì thực ra như thế này có khi nó lại tốt hơn.
Bởi vì nếu mà tự xem mình sẽ không hiểu.
Nhiều khi vào cái hệ thống mới mình không hiểu cái mục...
Mục tiêu của những cái...
Mini app ở trong đấy.
Những cái feature đấy đang để làm gì.
Và mọi người đang ứng dụng thực tế như thế nào.
Thì cũng khó.
Như thế này lại thành tốt hơn này.
Đấy.
Thúy lại dành được thời gian để có thể là...
Present qua về cái ứng dụng thực tế của nó.
Ừm.
Hôm nay là...
Mấy anh em rất là cảm ơn Thúy về việc này.
Đấy.
Và chắc là cũng chưa kịp ăn tối đúng không?
Vừa mới đi dẫn khách xong.
Ừ.
Nói chung là...
Nói chung là công việc này cũng làm được có lại giờ
khác nhau.
Ok. Cảm ơn nhiều nhá.
Have a good night.
Bao giờ về Việt Nam thì đi cafe nhá.
Ok. Cảm ơn Hiếu nhá.
Chúc mọi người thành công nhá.
Rõ ràng.
Nếu mọi người trong này có thiết kế được ra app gì
thì nhớ chia sẻ để mình xem thôi.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Lúc đấy có Hiếu thì phải nhờ lấy feedback ý chứ.
Thải mái. Thải mái.
Ok. Ok.
Bye bye. Cảm ơn cả nhà.
Bye bye.
Ok. Cảm ơn cả nhà.